Nein zu noch mehr Flüchtlingen damit
wirbt er für sich und seine Partei das
ist Norbert Kleinwächter was glaubt ihr
für wen sitzt Kleinwächter im Bundestag
genau für die AFD okay das war
einigermaßen einfach denn Politik gegen
Flüchtlinge ist ja das Markenzeichen der
AFD ein zweites Markenzeichen die AFD
ist sehr fit im Umgang mit den sozialen
Medien weil sie schon lange vor den
anderen Bundestagsparteien und jetzt hat
sie schon wieder die Nase fahren AFD man
kleinen Wächter benutzt KI für seine
Posts künstliche Intelligenz ich habe
mit meinem YouTube-Kanal glaube ich mehr
Abonnenten als die SPD-Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag wir haben mit ihm
darüber gesprochen wie die AFD mit KI
Reichweite erzählt und ob KI wie tätige
in der Lage ist mein Geburtsdatum
herauszufinden darum geht es in unserer
neuen Folge von Inside Qualitäts an
deren Ende ich dieses mal ein paar Tipps
für euch habe wie ihr nicht auf KI
generierte Bilder reinfallt los geht's
[Applaus]
hi herzlich willkommen ich bin Nicole
Diekmann kurz mal ein paar Infos zu mir
warum die wichtig sind erkläre ich euch
gleich kurz Geduld also ich bin
Journalistin und wurde am 17 märz 1978
geboren in Gütersloh so und jetzt gucken
wir mal was Chat GPT über mich weiß ganz
schnell falls ihr es noch nicht wisst
Chat GPT steht für generativ Transformer
und ist ein Chatbot der KI einsetzt und
mit Nutzern über textbasierte
Nachrichten zu kommunizieren also
Achtung das hier kommuniziert er über
mich Nicole Diekmann ist eine deutsche
Journalistin und Moderatorin sie wurde
am 5 November
1979 in Hildesheim Deutschland geboren
das spuckt also tschechische über mich
aus davon stimmt fast nichts künstliche
Intelligenz ja doch wohl eher künstliche
Dummheit aber gut das hätte GPT mich
nicht kennt geschenkt ist Chat GPT nicht
als Enzyklopädie gedacht hätte ich jetzt
geschrieben Chat GPT schreibt mir einen
guten Einstieg für ein youtube-format
zum Thema KI dann hätte das
wahrscheinlich geklappt Chat ist also
nicht Wikipedia und ich bin kein Super
Promi so wie zum Beispiel der Papst auf
den kommen wir hier heute auch noch ein
paar von euch können sich wahrscheinlich
schon denken warum aber erstmal würde
ich euch gerne zeigen wie schlau KI ist
KI kann nämlich super sein hilfreich
kreativ lustig aber auch gefährlich und
das zeige ich euch jetzt am Beispiel
Norbert Kleinwächter die AFD und KI
Norbert Kleinwächter stellvertretender
Fraktionschef der AFD der hat früh
erkannt wie super sich KI benutzen lässt
manche sagen auch missbrauchen aber mal
von Anfang an das Thema der AFD sind
Flüchtlinge die will sie nicht das
betont sie auch ständig in Reden
Debatten Interviews und in den sozialen
Netzwerken Norbert Kleinwächter macht
das natürlich auch in den vergangenen
Monaten hat er auf sich aufmerksam
gemacht weil er die der AFD
Kernbotschaften wie zum Beispiel keine
Flüchtlinge mit Maschinen generierten
Bildern versieht wir zeigen euch jetzt
eins wir haben lange vorher überlegt ob
wir das tun und das Bild damit weiter
verbreiten sollen und uns dafür
entschieden weil wir finden ihr müsst
schon wissen worüber ich hier und auch
gleich mit kleinen Wächter selber
spreche das Bild das aber Instagram
gepostet hat ist höchst problematisch
aber wir haben extra ein Fake drüber
gelegt um zu zeigen das ist nicht echt
und wichtig entspricht auch nicht der
Realität also hier ist es krass oder
Flüchtlinge sind hier ausschließlich
relativ junge Männer alle haben dunkle
Haare und dunkle Augen und alle sind sie
aggressiv sie wirken feindlich
gefährlich und machen Angst ich habe
aber Kleinwächter gefragt warum er ein
KI generiertes Bild benutzt und warum
die Flüchtlinge dies zeigen soll darauf
so dargestellt sind ich habe dieses
diesen Sachverhalt mit künstlicher
Intelligenz in der Tat illustriert und
illustrieren bedeutet immer sozusagen
etwas besonders hervorheben also nicht
fotorealistisch darstellen sondern in
gewisser Weise auch über betonen und
wenn ich über illegale Grenzübertritte
Rede wenn ich über hochkriminelle
Geschäfte rede dann rede ich in der Tat
über Aggressionen und dann rede ich auch
in der Tat über eine gefährliche
Situation für Deutschland tja das ist
eben illegale Migration um
Schleuserbanden geht das steht nicht auf
diesem Bild dafür sei das Thema zu
komplex sagt Kleinwächter er nimmt also
mindestens in Kauf dass das
missverständlich bleibt vielleicht will
er das auch das ist aber Spekulation das
ist sich bei dem Bild um eine
Illustration handelt sagt er auch nur
gibt es trotzdem zwei Probleme erstens
ich behaupte mal dass nicht jeder gleich
erkennt dass das gar kein echtes Bild
ist wenn ich meine Brille nicht auf habe
sehe ich das zum Beispiel nicht zweitens
Leute konsumieren Social Media ja oft
auf dem Smartphone kleiner Bildschirm
man sitzt im Bus da guckt man nicht
immer zu 100% voll konzentriert drauf
und sieht eben nicht immer ob das nun
ein Foto oder ein Illustration ist so
wird also auf unbewussten emotionalen
Ebene Stimmung gegen Flüchtlinge
geschürt Juristen die sich das Bild
angeschaut haben haben mir gesagt da
könnte man durchaus prüfen ob der
Straftatbestand der Volksverhetzung
erfüllt ist es ist mittlerweile ohne
weiteres möglich solche Bilder auch so
erstellen zu lassen dass sie total echt
wirken mit journey open ai Dream Studio
das sind nur drei Dienste die sowas auch
für line ganz unkompliziert hinkriegen
das Ergebnis kann total lustig und
völlig unverfänglich sein aber eben auch
das Gegenteil davon hier noch ein
Beispiel Donald Trump wird verhaftet
ging war ein paar Wochen viral ist aber
nie passiert könnte aber rein
theoretisch sein gegen den Ex
Präsidenten laufen ja gleich mehrere
Verfahren und jetzt stellt euch doch mal
vor so ein Bild macht die Hunde und es
gelingt Trump schon wieder seine
Anhänger zum Protest aufzurufen das ist
ja schon mal passiert 2021 als Trump die
Lüge von der gestohlenen Wahl verbreitet
und seine Fans dazu aufgestachelt hat
das Kapitel zustimmen dabei sterben fünf
Menschen hunderte wurden verletzt solche
Bilder sind also nichts anderes als
zündeln und machen wir uns nichts vor
erst der Anfang man muss keine
Hellseherin sein um zu wissen da steht
im US-Wahlkampf noch einiges bevor KI
spielt im Moment auch eine große Rolle
auf EU-Ebene die ki-verordnung soll die
gefährlichsten Risiken von künstlicher
Intelligenz eindämmen denn das ist eine
Menge riesigen gibt das sagen alle
Experten im März ist sogar ein offener
Brief erschienen in dem renommierte
Fachleute fordern mit dem Training von
leistungsstarken ki-modellen für sechs
Monate zu pausieren zu den
Unterzeichnern gehören namhafte Personen
der Mitbegründer von Apple z.B oder auch
twitter-chef Elon Musk das ist zu so
einem Moratorium aber wirklich kommt
glaubt kaum jemand und nicht wenige
vermuten dahinter auch eher ein Trick so
könnte man zum Beispiel Zeit gewinnen um
hinter den Kulissen in diesen sechs
Monaten weiter an den eigenen Programmen
zurück zur ki-verordnung Achtung jetzt
wird's ein bisschen technisch im Entwurf
finden sich Forderungen wie das Verbot
von biometrischen erkennungssystemen in
Echtzeit in öffentlich zugänglichen
Räumen und das Verbot von biometrischen
kategorisierungssystemen die sensible
Daten verwenden wir zum Beispiel Rasse
Geschlecht ethnische Zugehörigkeit oder
auch das Verbot des wahllosen Auslesens
biometrischer Daten aus sozialen
Netzwerken gute wichtige Punkte nur die
kiv-verordnung ist noch nicht fertig
verhandelt und erst recht noch nicht
verabschiedet das dauert ja immer seine
Zeit aber wie läuft's denn eigentlich
hier so in Deutschland wo man ja die
Digitalisierung schon verschlafen hat
erleben wir das gerade beim Thema KI
wieder also quasi digitale Revolution
verpennen Reloaded oder läuft dieses Mal
vielleicht besser
die Ampel und k.i ich habe hier vor mir
eine kleine Anfrage die die Linke
neulich der Bundesregierung gestellt hat
grob gesagt geht es darin um die Frage
wie fit ist die Ampel eigentlich in
Sachen KI ich zitiere mal aus ein paar
Antworten die Bundesregierung
beschäftigt sich regelmäßig mit
technologischen Neuheiten und hat die
ki-basierte Software Chat auch bereits
getestet
schon getestet sorry aber das haben wir
doch inzwischen wirklich alle oder und
weiter bundländer Gremien die sich
explizit nur zu Planung Einsatz
Evaluierung und möglichen Risiken Fehler
oder Optimierungsbedarf beim Einsatz von
ki-anwendungen abstimmen sind der
Bundesregierung nicht bekannt
tja könnte besser laufen sagt auch
Professorin Katharina 2 um über
ki-systeme zu sprechen müssen wir
eigentlich vier verschiedene Dinge
besprechen haben wir die Daten haben wir
die Methoden haben wir die Ideen und
haben wir die Möglichkeiten zur
Umsetzung und an allen vier Punkten
hapert es ein wenig wer nicht schnell
versteht wie man ein neues Werkzeug
einsetzen kann dann werden es andere
schneller einsetzen effektiver sein
kostengünstiger sein und das kann nicht
gut sein für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland findet ihr das das
vertrauenseinflussen klingt ich nicht
die Wirtschaft abgehängt und wir alle
ständig konfrontiert mit der Frage ob
wir unseren Augen eigentlich noch trauen
können im besten Fall glauben wir dass
Angela Merkel gerade irgendwo auf
irgendeiner Wasserrutsche ganz viel Spaß
hat in einem deutlich schlimmeren
glauben wir aber dass der Stereotype
Flüchtling aggressiv und
furchteinflößend ist ja das ist den
Flüchtling überhaupt gibt ich habe hier
noch eine aussagekräftige Antwort der
Bundesregierung auf die Kleine Anfrage
der Linken euch die Erforschung der
Möglichkeiten und Effekte des Einsatzes
von KI in der Hochschulbildung ist
Gegenstand einer Förderlinie des
Forschungsschwerpunktes Forschung zu
digitalen Hochschulbildung des
Bundesministeriums für Bildung und
Forschung die Achtung in der 19
Legislaturperiode veröffentlicht wurde
in der 19 Legislaturperiode das war die
Vorgängerregierung übersetzt heißt das
da haben wir jetzt erstmal noch nichts
gemacht und nicht nur da ich habe mit
Anke Domstadt Berg darüber gesprochen
Anke domscheid Berg sitzt für die Linke
im Bundestag und ist im Bundestag die
digital-expertin haben Sie das Gefühl
dass die deutsche Politik schon wieder
eine digitale Revolution verschläft wie
seinerzeit schon das Internet und später
Social Media
sie versucht genau das nicht zu tun
indem sie massiv KI einsetzt sie macht
aber genau das noch mal was ihr zum
Beispiel bei der Digitalisierung der
Verwaltung auch schon falsch gemacht hat
ihr fehlen nämlich die Strukturen dafür
man hat sogar über die Schaffung dieser
Strukturen nachgedacht drei verschiedene
Institutionen wollte man dazu ins Leben
rufen eine Beratungs- und
evaluierungseinrichtungen abgekürzt Beki
für die öffentliche Verwaltung und
künstliche Intelligenz ein
Kompetenzzentrum für künstliche
Intelligenz und nochmal eine Algorithmen
Bewertungsstelle für Behörden mit
besonderen Sicherheitsaufgaben alle drei
sind total wichtig alle drei existieren
nach wie vor nicht für das für die
Algorithmen Bewertungsstelle da gibt es
Budgets im Haushalt schon seit 2021 also
noch in der alten Legislatur getan hat
sich leider nichts und im Haushalt steht
sogar bis 2025 weiter die Planung dieser
Stelle drin also ich weiß nicht wie
lange die noch planen wollen wir
brauchen das jetzt
ja klingt verschneit oder ich habe mal
den Regierungssprecher gefragt was da
eigentlich los ist ich glaube nicht dass
man es in irgendeiner Weise unterschätzt
aber ich habe ja schon gesagt dass ich
keinen aktuellen Sachstand zu den Fragen
habe da muss ich mich schlau machen es
läuft nicht gut und müsste aber
eigentlich langsam mal laufen denn die
ki-maschinen zu bedienen ist
kinderleicht Ihre Ergebnisse zu erkennen
wird aber immer immer schwieriger ich
hatte euch am Anfang angekündigt dass
wir noch über den Papst reden und das
tun wir jetzt da ist er dieses Bild
liefer ein paar Wochen rauf und runter
coole Jacke oder ist natürlich ein Fake
wisst ihr bestimmt schon weil dieses
Bild ja eben fast überall zu sehen war
auch deshalb übrigens weil so viele
drauf reingefallen sind ich auch denn es
sieht super echt aus keine sechs Finger
keine seltsame Achsverschiebung ist hier
irgendwo zu sehen denn das sind momentan
noch die typischen Fehler die KI begeht
die uns dabei helfen Fakes zu erkennen
hier ist das rein von der Bildqualität
her praktisch unmöglich deshalb sind
enorm viele Leute darauf reingefallen
der Autor des Newsletters garbage day
Ryan Broderick nannte es denn auch den
ersten echten KI fehlinformationsfall
auf massenebene diese Bilder sind
natürlich deswegen gefährlich weil wir
uns in den letzten 100 Jahren daran
gewöhnt haben dass das was von Kameras
aufgenommen wird fast immer richtig ist
wir brauchen jetzt wieder einen
Journalismus in dem genug Zeit und Geld
da ist Dinge wirklich vor Ort zu
recherchieren mit den Leuten zu sprechen
das scheint mir der einzige Weg zu sein
wie wir sicherstellen können dass die
Nachrichten die wir erhalten tatsächlich
auch der Wahrheit und den Fakten
entspricht das richtet sich also an uns
eine Journalisten aber für euch habe ich
heute auch noch was was Neues bei uns
bei inside-service wir beantworten euch
heute zum Schluss nämlich die Frage was
kann ich tun um die Echtheit von Bildern
zu prüfen
Service
die schlechte Nachricht zuerst die KI
ist viel besser darin Bilder zu fälschen
als gefälschte Bilder zu entlarven das
liegt unter anderem daran dass viel mehr
Leute an der Entwicklung vom Bild
erzeugender ki-arbeiten als eine
Entwicklung von sogenannter Detektion
Software das Verhältnis liegt laut
Profis bei 100:1 aber ihr seid trotzdem
nicht völlig aufgeschmissen das
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
hat mehrere Tipps veröffentlicht um KI
generierte Bilder zu erkennen erstens
achtet immer aufs Gesicht fast immer
handelt es sich bei deepacks und
Transformationen das Gesichts sieht die
Haut zu glatt oder zu gründlich aus
passt das Alter des Gesichts zum Rest
des Körpers sehen die Schattenwürfe rund
um Augen und Augenbrauen echt aus die
Fakes halten sich nicht immer an die
physikalischen Gesetzmäßigkeiten einer
Szene 2 sehen die Spiegelungen in
Brillengläser realistisch aus drittens
wie wirkt die Gesichtsbehaarung gibt es
zu viel davon oder zu wenig erscheint
sie natürlich viertens wir sehen die
Grübchen aus fünftens bei Videos solltet
ihr unbedingt auf das zwinkern achten
oft zwinkern die Personen bei die Fakes
zu viel oder zu wenig und auch die
Lippenbewegung und die Darstellung der
Zähne können Fälschungen entlarven und
das wäre mein Tipp wenn ihr Zweifel habt
dann verbreitet ein Bild lieber nicht
Fazit
die Bundesregierung muss langsam mal den
Turbo anschmeißen und wir auch sonst
werden wir abgehängt und geflutet mit
Falschinformationen das kennen wir ja
schon aus den letzten Jahren erinnert
euch an Fake News zur corona-zeiten so
was wie das Trinken von Chlordioxid
würde die Viren töten solche und andere
zum Teil echt gefährliche
Lügengeschichten haben so viele Leute
tatsächlich geglaubt dass zum Beispiel
eine Münchner Klinik eine ganze Seite
gebaut hat auf der sie mit solchen
Quatsch aufräumt wenn jetzt auch noch
Bilder dazu kommen die auf einer ganz
anderen Ebene unseren verbreiten da
müssen wir echt alle aufpassen und es
steht noch eine Frage im Raum nämlich
die wie die anderen Parteien und auch
wir umgehen sollten mit Bildern wie
denen von Norbert Kleinwächter seine
Beispiel werden bestimmt noch weitere
folgen bisher ist da z.B aus den anderen
Parteien noch wenig zugekommen wie seht
ihr das wie sollte man damit umgehen ich
hoffe diese Folge hat euch Spaß gemacht
falls ja abonniert uns lasst ein Like da
und diskutiert gern unten in den
Kommentaren ich bin Nicole Dietmann
komme nicht aus Hildesheim und freue
mich auf die Diskussion